the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
because if I was not this would be
basically the last topic we would ever
see and this is arguably probably the
most important topic in statistics or at
least that's probably the reason why
most of you are taking this class
because regression implies prediction
and prediction is what people are all
after now right you don't need to
understand what the model for the
financial market is if you actually have
a formula to predict what the stock
prices are gonna be tomorrow and
regression in a way allows us to do that
and we'll start with a very simple
version of regression which is linear
regression which is the most standard
one and then we'll move on to slightly
more advanced notions such as
nonparametric regression at least we're
gonna see the principles behind it and
I'll touch upon a little bit of high
dimensional regression which is what
people are doing today so the goal of
regression is to try to predict one
variable based on another variable
alright so here the notation is very
important it's extremely standard it
goes from 1 it goes everywhere
essentially and essentially you have we
were trying to explain why as a function
of X ok which is the usual y equals f of
X question except that you know if you
look at a calculus class people tell you
y equals f of X and they give you
specific form for f and then you do
something here we're just gonna try to
estimate what this link function is and
this is why we often call why the
explained variable and X the explanatory
variable all right so we're statistician
so we start with data all right then
what does our data look like well it
looks like a bunch of input/output to
this relationship all right so we have a
bunch of X I Y those are pairs and I can
do a scatter plot of those guys right so
each point here has a x-coordinate
she's exciting a y-coordinate which is
why I'm here I have a bunch of end
points and I just draw them like that
now if so the functions we're going to
be interested in they're often function
of the form y equals a plus B times X
okay and that means that this function
looks like this so if I do excellent why
this function looks exactly like line
and clearly those points are not on line
and it will basically never happen that
those winds are on a line there's a
famous t-shirt from I think UC Berkeley
stats Department that shows this picture
and put a line in between them like
we're gonna see it and it says a
statisticians oh so many points and you
still managed to miss all of them and
and so basically essentially we don't
believe that this relationship Y is
equal to a plus BX is true but maybe up
to some noise and that's where the
statistics is gonna come into play
there's gonna be some random noise
that's gonna play out and hopefully the
noise is gonna be spread out evenly so
that we can average it if we have enough
points average it out okay
and so this epsilon here is not
necessarily due to randomness but again
just like we did modeling in the first
place
it essentially accounts for everything
we don't understand about this
relationship alright so for example so
here I'm not gonna be okay give me one
second so I'll see it we'll see an
example in a second but the idea here is
that if you have data and if you believe
that it's of the form a plus BX plus
some noise you're trying to find the
line that will explain your data the
best right in the terminology we've been
using before this would be the most
likely line that explains the data so we
can see that it's likely we've just
added another dimension to our
statistical problem we don't have just
X's but we have Y's and we're trying to
find the most likely explanation of the
relationship between y and X all right
and so in practice the way it's going to
look like is that we're going to have
basically two parameters to find the
slope B and the intercept a and given
data the goal is going to be to try to
find the best possible line all right
so what we're going to find is not
exactly a and
the ones that actually generated the
data but some Esther estimators of those
parameters a hat and B hat constructed
from the data alright so we'll see that
more generally but we're not going to go
too much in the details of this if
there's actually quite a bit that you
can understand if you do what's called
univariate regression when X is actually
a real valued random variable so when
this happens this is called univariate
regression and when X is in our p4p
larger than or equal to two this is
called multivariate regression okay and
so here we're just trying to explain why
is a plus BX plus Epsilon and here we're
gonna have something more complicated
we're gonna have Y which is equal to a
plus B 1 X 1 plus B 2 X 2 plus B P X P
plus epsilon where X is equal to the
coordinates of X are given by X 1 2 X
PRP ok so it's still linear right they
still add all the coordinates of X with
a coefficient in front of them but it's
a bit more complicated than just one
coefficient for one coordinate of X ok
so we'll come back to multivariate
regression there's a of course you can
write this as a X transpose B right so
this entire thing here this linear
combination is of the form X transpose B
where B is the vector that has
coordinates V 1 - d/p
ok sorry here it's in Rd P is the
natural notation all right so our goal
here in the univariate one is to try to
write a model make sense of this little
twiddle here
essentially from a statistical modeling
question is going to be able to the
question is going to be what
distributional assumptions you want to
put on epsilen are you gonna say they're
Gaussian are gonna say they're binomial
okay are you gonna say they're binomial
or gonna say they're Burnley so that's
gonna be what we're gonna make sense and
then we're gonna try to find a method to
estimate a and B and then maybe we're
gonna try to do some inference about a
and B maybe test if a and B take certain
values if they're less than something
maybe find some confidence regions for a
and B all right so why would you want to
do this well I'm sure all of you have an
application why if I give you some X
you're trying to predict put wise
mission learning is all about doing this
right without maybe trying to even
understand the physics behind this
they're saying well you give me a bag of
words I want to understand whether it's
gonna be a spam or not you give me a
bunch of in the economic indicators I
want you to tell me how much I should be
selling my car for you give me a bunch
of measurements on some patient I want
you to predict how this person is gonna
respond to my drug and things like this
all right then so often we actually
don't have much modeling intuition about
what the relationship between x and y is
and this linear thing is basically the
simplest function we can think of
arguably linear functions are the
simplest functions that are not trivial
otherwise we would just say well it's
just pretty X Y to be a constant meaning
it does not depend on X but if you want
it to depend on X linear functions are
basically as simple as it gets
turns out amazingly this does the trick
quite often
all right so for example if you look at
economics you might want to assume that
the demand is a linear function of the
price all right so if your price is zero
there's going to be a certain demand and
as the price increases the demand is
going to move do you think B is going to
be positive or negative here what
typically it's negative unless we're
talking about maybe luxury goods where
you know the more expensive the more
people actually want it I mean if we're
talking about actual economic demand
it's probably definitely negative all
right
it doesn't have to be you know clearly
linear so that you can actually make it
linear transform it into some linear so
for example you have this like
multiplicative relationship right P you
know PV equals NRT which is the idea
ideal gas law if you want to actually
write this relationship if you want to
predict what the pressure is going to be
as a function of the volume and the
temperature and well let's assume that
so n is the Avogadro constant and let's
assume that the radius is actually fixed
then you have basically you take the log
on each side right so you get PV equals
NRT okay so so what that means is that
log PV is equal to log in RT so that
means that log P plus log V is equal to
log and R plus log T ok so this is here
we said that R is constant so this is
actually a constant I'm gonna call it a
and then that means that log P is equal
to minus log V seriously that log P is
equal to a minus log V Plus log T ok and
so in particular if I write be equal to
negative 1 and C equal to plus 1 this
gives me the formula that I have here
now again it might be the case that's
you know this is the ideal gas law also
in practice if I start recording
pressure and temperature and volume
those things I might make measurement
errors it might be slightly different
conditions it's such a way that I'm not
gonna get exactly those and I'm just
gonna put this little twiddle to account
for the fact that the points that I'm
gonna be recording for log pressure log
volume and log temperature not gonna be
exactly on one line okay they're gonna
be close
actually in those physics experiments
usually they're very close so it's
actually because the conditions are
controlled in under lab experiments so
it means that the noise is very small
and but for other cases like demand and
price this is not a law of physics and
so this might change even the linear
structure is probably not clear right at
some points there's probably gonna be
some weird curvature happening alright
so this light is just to tell you maybe
you don't have obviously a linear
relationship but maybe you do if you
start taking logs expect Exponential's
squares you can sometimes take the
product of two variables things like
this right so this is variable
transformation and it's mostly domain
specific so we're not gonna go into much
details of this any questions all right
so now I'm gonna be given so if we start
thinking a little more about what those
coefficients should be well remember so
just everybody's clear why I don't put
the little I here
[Applause]
right
I don't put the little I because I'm
just talking about a generic X and a
Jarek Y but the observations are x1 y1
right so typically on the blackboard I'm
often gonna write the only X Y but the
data really is x1 y1 all the way to X n
yn right so those are this points in
this two-dimensional plot and but if I
think of those as being copies
independent copies of
of the pair XY okay they have to have
the to contain the relationship and so
when I talk about distribution of those
random variables I can only I talk about
the distribution of XY and that's the
same alright so the first thing you
might want to ask is well if I have an
infinite amount of data what do i what
what can I hope to get for a and B right
if my sample size goes to infinity then
I should actually know exactly what the
distribution of XY is and so there
should be an A and a B that captures
this linear relationship between y and X
okay and so in particular we're gonna
try to ask the population or theoretic
values of a and B and you can see that
you can actually compute them explicitly
so let's just try to find how so as I
said we have a bunch of points on this
line close to a line and I'm trying to
find the best fit all right so this guy
is not a good fit this guy is not a good
fit and we know that this guy is a good
fit somehow so we need to mathematically
formulate the fact that this line here
is better than this line here or better
than this line here so what we're trying
to do is to create a function that has
values that are smaller for this curve
and larger for these two curves and the
way we do it is by measuring the fit and
the fit is essentially the aggregate
distance of all the points to the curve
alright and there's many ways I can
measure the distance to a curve right so
if I want to find so let's just open a
parenthesis if I have a point here so
we're gonna do it for one point at a
time so if I have a point there's many
ways I can measure its distance to the
curve right I can measure it like that
that is one distance to the curve I can
measure it like that by having a right
angle here that is one distance to the
curve or I can measure it like that
that is another distance to the curve
right
there's many ways they can go for it it
turns out that one is actually going to
be fairly convenient for us and that's
the one that says let's look at the
square of the value of X on the curve
right so if this is the curve y is equal
to a plus BX now I'm gonna think of this
point as a random point capital X
capital y okay and so that means that
it's gonna be interesting it's gonna be
x1 x2 y1 or x2 y2 etc now I want to
measure the distance can somebody tell
me which of the three the first one the
second one or the third one this formula
expectation of Y minus a minus BX
squared is e is is which of the three is
it representing the second one where I
have the right angle okay everybody
agrees with this anybody wants to vote
for something else yeah the third one
who everybody agrees with the third one
so by default everybody's on the first
one yeah yeah it is the vertical
distance actually right so and the
reason is if it was the one with the
straight angle with the right angle it
would actually be very complicated
mathematical formula so let's just see
why right so and by why I mean why okay
so this is this means that this is my X
okay and this is my Y right so that
means that this point is XY so what I'm
measuring is the difference between Y
minus a plus B times X right this is the
thing I'm gonna take the expectation of
the square and then the expected so a
plus B times X if this is this line this
is this point so that's this value here
this value here is a plus B X right
so what I'm really measuring is the
difference between Y and M plus BX which
is this distance here and since I like
things like Pythagoras theorem I'm
actually gonna put a square here before
I take the expectation okay so now this
is a random variable this is this random
variable and so I want a number so I'm
gonna turn it into a deterministic
number and the way I do this is by
taking expectation okay and doing
expectation if you think expectation
should be close to average this is the
same thing as saying I want that in
average the Y's are close to the a plus
BX right so we're doing it in
expectation but that's gonna translate
into doing it in average for all the
points all right so this is the thing I
want to measure so that's this vertical
distance yeah oh yeah okay sorry I'm
just this is my fault actually maybe we
should close those chains
okay you know I cannot do just one at a
time
okay so the all right so now that I do
those vertical distances I can I can ask
well now I have this function right to
have a function that takes two
parameters a and B maps it to the
expectation of Y minus a plus B X
squared sorry the square is here and I
can ask well this is a function that
measures the fit of the parameters a and
B right this function should be small
the value of this function here function
of a and B that measures how close the
point X Y is to the line a plus B times
X but Y is equal a plus B times X in the
expectation okay agreed this is what we
we just said and you can think again if
you're not comfortable with the reason
why it's you can expectations just think
about having data points in taking the
average value for this guy so it's
basically an aggregate distance of the
points to there to the red line okay
everybody agrees this is a legitimate
measure if all my points were on the
line if my distribution if Y was
actually equal to a plus B X for some a
and B then this function would be equal
to 0 for the correct a and B right if
therefore well it's going to depend on
how much noise I'm getting but it's
still going to be minimized for the best
one
so let's minimize this thing so here I
don't make any again sorry I don't make
a
assumption on on the distribution of X
or Y here I assume somehow that the
variance of X is not equal to zero can
somebody tell me why yeah no here I've
actually in this expectation of the
square if I wanted to write the square
of the expectation I would just do this
so so let's just make it clear right do
you want me to put an extra set of
parentheses that's what you want me to
do okay
that's the one that makes sense so the
square of the expectation the
expectation of the square sorry yeah
dyslexia all right any question yeah
why so you know the answer to your
question so I just want you to use the
words that right so why would you want
to use the fourth power yeah so that
would be the maximum likelihood
estimator that you're describing to me
right I can actually write the
likelihood of a pair of numbers a B and
if I know this that's actually what's
gonna come into it because I know that
the density is gonna come into play when
I talk about there but here I'm just
talking about if this is the mechanical
tool I'm just saying let's minimize the
distance to the curve another thing I
could have done is take the absolute
value of this thing for example I just
decided to take this square before I did
it okay
so regardless of what I'm doing I'm just
taking the squares because that's just
gonna be convenient for me to do my
computations for now but we don't have
any statistical model at this point all
right I didn't say anything that Y
follows this X follows this I'm just
doing minimal assumptions as we go all
right so the variance of X is not equal
to zero can somebody tell me why what
would happen is my what would my point
cloud point looked like if the variance
of X was equal to zero yeah they would
all be at the same point so it's gonna
be hard for me to start fitting in a
line right I mean best-case scenario I
have this X it has variance zero so this
is the expectation of X and all my
points have the same expectation and so
yes I could probably fit that line but I
wouldn't help very much for other X's
right so I need a bit of variance so
that things spread out a little bit and
and okay I'm gonna have to do this
I think it's just my okay it's okay
alright so I'm gonna put a little bit of
list variance and the other thing is
here I don't want to do much more but
I'm actually going to think of X as
having mean zero and the way I do this
is as follows let's define X tilde which
is X minus the expectation of X okay so
definitely the expectation of X tilde is
what zero okay and so now I want to
minimize in a be expectation of Y minus
a plus B x squared and what I'm going to
the way I'm gonna do this
[Applause]
is by turning X into X tilde and
stuffing the extra and putting the extra
expectation of X into the a okay so I'm
going to write this as expectation of Y
minus a plus B expectation of X which
I'm gonna call a tilde and plus B X
tilde okay and everybody agrees with
this so now I have two parameters a
tilde and B and I'm gonna pretend that
now X still so now it's the role of X is
played by X tilde which is now a which
is now a centered random variable okay
so I'm gonna call this guy a child above
foot for my computations I'm gonna call
it a so how do I find the minimum of
this thing they're very weak all to 0
right so here it's a quadratic thing
it's going to be like that I take the
derivative set it to zero so I'm first
gonna take the derivative with respect
to a and set it equal to zero so that's
equivalent to saying that the
expectation of well here I'm gonna pick
up a 2y minus a plus B X tilde is equal
to zero
and then I also have that the derivative
with respect to B is equal to zero which
is equivalent to the expectation of well
I have a negative sign somewhere so let
me put it here minus two X tilde Y minus
a plus B X tilde okay see yeah that's
why I don't want to put too many
parentheses
[Music]
okay so I just took the derivative with
respect to a which is just basically the
square and then I have a negative one
that comes out from inside and then I
take the derivative with respect to B
and I have since B has excelled in
factor it comes out as well all right so
the - choose really won't matter for me
and so now I have two equations the
first equation well it's pretty simple
it's just telling me that the
expectation of Y minus a is equal to
zero so what I know is that a is equal
to the expectation of Y and really that
was HL de which implies that the a I
want is actually equal to the
expectation of Y minus B times the
expectation of X okay just because a
tilde is a plus B times the expectation
of X
so that's for my a and then for my B I
use the second one so the second one
tells me that the expectation of X tilde
Y is equal to a plus B times the
expectation of X tilde which is zero
right
okay but this is actually a tilde in
this problem so it's actually a plus B
expectation of X now this is the
expectation of the product of two random
variables but X tilde is centered right
it's X minus expectation of X so this
thing is actually equal to the
covariance between X and Y by definition
of covariance so now I have everything I
need right how do I just I'm sorry about
that so I have everything I need now I'm
just I mean you have two equations with
two unknowns and all I have to do is to
basically plug it in so it's essentially
telling me that the covariance of X Y so
the first equation tells me that the
covariance of X Y is equal to a plus B
expectation of X but a is expectation of
Y minus B expectation of X so it's well
actually maybe I should start with B
oh sorry sorry sorry okay I forgot one
thing I'm sorry this is not true right
I forgot this term X tilde multiplies X
tilde here so what I'm left with is X
tilde it's minus B times the expectation
of X tilde squared so that's actually
minus B times the variance of X tilde
because X tilde is already centered okay
which is actually the variance of X okay
so now I have that this thing is
actually a plus B expectation of X minus
B variance of X and I also have that a
is equal to expectation of Y minus B
expectation of X okay so if I sum the
two right so if I sum the two those guys
are gonna cancel those guys are going to
cancel and so what I'm going to be left
with is covariance of XY is equal to
expectation of X expectation of Y and
then I'm left with this term here minus
B times the variance of X and so that
tells me that B what I still have the
variance there
yeah but sex till the centre-right so
you just you just need to have one that
centered for this to work right yeah I
mean you didn't check it but basically
when you're going to have the product of
the expectations you only need one of
the two in the product to be zero so the
product is zero so okay why do I keep my
so I get a a and then the B expectation
okay so that's probably earlier that I
made a mistake so I get eight so this
was a tilde fear about that so that
tells me that HL de maybe yeah it's not
super fear of me - yeah okay I think I
know where I made a mistake I should not
have centered I wanted to make my life
easier and I should not have done that
and the reason is a tilde depends on B
so when I take the derivative with
respect to B what I'm left with here
since eight Zelda depends on B when I
take the derivative of this guy
I actually don't get a tilde here but I
really get sorry so again this was not
so that's the first one yes so this is
actually X here
all right when I take the derivative
with respect to B and so now what I'm
left with is that the expectation so I
yeah I'm basically left with nothing
that helps so I'm sorry about that let's
start from the beginning because this is
not getting us anywhere and any kind of
fix is not gonna help so let's just do
it again sorry about that
so let's not Center or anything and just
just do it brute force because we're
gonna have x squared all right partial
with respect to a is giving equal zero
is equivalent so my -2 is gonna cancel
right so I'm gonna actually forget about
this so it's actually telling me that
the expectation of Y minus a plus BX is
equal to zero which is equivalent to a
plus B expectation of X is equal to the
expectation of Y now if I take the
derivative with respect to B and set it
equal to zero this is telling me that
the expectation of well it's the same
thing except that this time I'm gonna
pull out an X this guy is equal to zero
this guy's not here and so that implies
that the expectation of XY is equal to a
times the expectation of X plus B times
the expectation of x squared okay
all right so the first one is actually
not giving me much I need to actually
work with the two of those guys so I'm
gonna take the first so let me rewrite
those to make well inequalities that I
have I have 8 plus B e of X is equal to
e of Y and then I have G of XY ok and
now that what I do is that I take the I
multiply this guy so I want to cancel
one of these things right so what I'm
gonna yeah so I'm gonna take this guy
and I'm gonna multiply it by e of X and
take the difference okay so I do times e
of X and then I take the differ
I take this I take the sum of those two
and then those two terms are gonna
cancel ok so then that tells me that B
times e of x squared plus the
expectation of X Y is equal to so this
guy is the one that cancelled then I get
this guy here expectation of X times the
expectation of Y plus the guy that
remains here which is B times the
expectation of x squared so here I have
B expectation of X the whole thing
squared and here I have B expectation of
X square so if I pull this guy here what
do I get B times the variance of X ok so
I'm gonna move here and this guy here
when I move this guy here I get
expectation
of X times y minus the expectation of x
times the expectation of Y so this is
actually telling me that the covariance
of x and y is equal to b times the
variance of X and so that then that
tells me that B is equal to covariance
of X Y divided by the variance of X and
that's why I actually need the variance
of X to be nonzero because I couldn't do
that otherwise and because if it was it
would mean that B should be plus
infinity which is what the limit of this
guy is when the variance goes to zero
okay or negative infinity I cannot sort
them out all right
so I'm sorry about the mess but that
should be more clear then a of course
you can write it as a fogging in the
value of B so you know it it's only a
function of your distribution right so
what are the characteristics of the
district so distribution can have a
bunch of things it can have moments of
order 4 of order 26 it can have heavy
tails or light tails but when you
compute least squares the only thing
that matters are the variance of X the
expectation of the individual ones and
really what captures how Y changes when
you change X is is captured in the
coherence the rest is really just
normalization all right this is just
telling you I want things to cross the y
axis at the right place I won't think to
cross the x axis at the right place but
the slope is really captured by how much
more coherence you have relative to the
variance of X ok so this is essentially
setting the scale for the x axis and
this is telling you for a unit scale
this is the unit of Y that you're
changing okay so we have explicit forms
and what I could do if I wanted to
estimate those things is just say well
again we have expectations right D
covariance is the expectation of X Y
minus the product of the expectations I
could replace expectations by averages
and get an empirical covariance just
like we can replace the expectations for
the variance and get a sample covariance
and this is basically what we're gonna
be doing alright this is essentially
what you want the problem is that if you
view it that way you sort of prevent
yourself from being able to solve the
multivariate problem because it's only
in the univariate problem that you have
close form solutions for your problem
but if you actually go to multivariate
this is not where you want to replace
expectations by averages you actually
want to replace expectation by averages
here and once you do it here then you
can actually just solve the minimization
problem all right okay so one thing that
arises from this guy is that this is an
interesting formula all right think
about it if I if I have that Y is a plus
BX plus some noise now not things are no
longer on the on something I have that Y
is equal to a plus BX plus some noise
which is usually denoted by Epsilon so
that's the distribution right if I tell
you the distribution of X and I say Y is
a plus BX plus epsilon I tell you the
distribution of Y and if let me that
those two are independent you have a
distribution on Y so what happens is
that I can actually always say well you
know this is equivalent to saying that
epsilon is equal to Y minus a plus BX
right I can always write this as just I
mean it's a tautology but here for those
guys this is not for any guy right this
is really for the best fit a and B those
ones that satisfy this gradient is equal
to zero thing then what we had is that
the expectation of epsilon was equal to
expectation of Y
- a plus B expectation of X right by
linearity of the expectation which was
equal to zero so for this best fit we
have zero now the covariance between x
and y between sorry X and epsilon is
what well is the covariance between X
and well epsilon was y minus a plus BX
okay now the covariance is bilinear so
what I have is that the covariance of
this is the covariance of X and x y I'm
sorry of x and y minus the covariance
well minus a plus B covariance of X and
X which is the variance of X covariance
of X Y minus a plus B covariance
variance of X and
covariance okay I didn't write it so
here I have covariance of XY is equal to
be variance of X right so why what did I
convince of XY yeah that's because I
cannot do that with the covariance yeah
I have those averages again no because
this is centered right sorry this is
centered so this is actually equal to
the expectation of x times y minus a
plus BX right the covariance is equal to
the product just because this right
inside is actually centered so this is
the expectation of x times y minus the
expectation of a times X there are eight
times the expectation of X plus B minus
B times the expectation of x squared
well actually maybe I should not really
go too far so this is actually the one
that I need but if I stop here this is
actually equal to zero right those are
the same equations okay yeah so we're
just saying that if I actually believe
that this best fit was the one that gave
me the right parameters what would that
imply on the noise itself on this
epsilon so here we're actually just
trying to find some necessary condition
for the noise to hold for the noise and
so those conditions are that first the
expectation is 0 that's what we got here
and then that the covariance between the
noise and X has to be 0 as well ok so
those are actually conditions that the
noise must satisfy but the noise was
just not really defined as noise itself
we were just saying okay if we're gonna
put some assumptions on X on the epsilon
what do we better have so the first one
is that it's centered which is good
because otherwise the noise would shift
everything so now when you look at the a
linear regression model typically if you
look if you open a book it doesn't start
by saying let the noise be the
difference between Y and what I actually
want Y to be it says let's Y be a plus
BX plus epsilon so conversely if we
assume that this is the model that we
have then we're gonna have to assume
that epsilon we're going to assume that
epsilon is centered and that the
covariance between X and epsilon is 0
actually often we're gonna assume much
more and one way to ensure that those
two things are satisfied is to assume
that X is independent of epsilon for
example if you assume that X is
independent of Epsilon of course the
covariance is going to be zero or we
might assume that the conditional
expectation of epsilon given X is equal
to zero then that implies that okay
now the fact that it's centered is one
thing so if we make this assumption what
the only thing it's telling us is that
those abs that come right we started
from there
why is equal to a plus BX plus some
epsilon for some a and some B what it
turns out is that those ABS A's and B's
or actually the ones that you would get
by solving this expectation of square
thing all right so when you asked back
when you were following yeah so when you
asked you know why don't we take the
square for example or the power four or
something like this then here I'm saying
well if I have Y is equal to a plus BX I
don't actually need to put too much
assumptions on epsilon if epsilon is
actually satisfying those two things
expectation is equal to zero and
covariance with X is equal to zero then
the right a and B that I'm looking for
actually the ones that come with the
square not with power 4 or power 25 okay
so those are actually pretty weak
assumptions if we want to do inference
we're gonna have to assume right anymore
if we want to use t distributions at
some point for example and we will we're
gonna have to assume that epsilon has a
Gaussian distribution so if you want to
start doing more statistics beyond just
like doing this least squares thing
which is minimizing the squared
criterion you're actually gonna have to
put more assumptions but right now we
did not need them we only need that
epsilon has mean 0 and covariance 0 with
X ok so let's start with so that was
basically probabilistic right we're
trying to say if I were to do
probability and I we're trying to model
the relationship between two random
variables x and y in the form wise a
plus BX was some noise this is what
would come out everything was
expectations there was no data involved
so now let's go to the data problem
which is now I do not have I do not know
what those expectations are in
particular I don't know what the
covariance of x and y is and I don't
know what the expectation of X and the
expectation of Y's of Y are so I have
data to do that so how am I going to do
this well I'm just gonna say well if I
want x1 y1
xnyn and I'm going to assume that their
ID and I'm actually going to assume that
they have some model right so I'm going
to assume that I have that a so that why
I follows the same model so epsilon IR
ID and I won't say that absolute a sheen
of epsilon I is zero and covariance of X
I X 1 I is equal to zero so I'm going to
put the same model on all the data so
you can see that a is not a I and B is
not B is the same so as my data
increases I should be able to recover
the correct things as the size of my
data increases okay so this is what the
statistical problem look like you're
given the points there is a true line
from which this point was generated
right there was this line there was a
true a B that I used to draw the spa and
that was the line so first I picked an X
say uniformly at random on this interval
0 to 2 I said that was this one then I
said well I want Y to be a plus BX so it
should be here but then I'm going to add
some noise epsilon to go away again back
from this line and actually that's
actually mean here we actually got two
points correct on this line so there's
basically two epsilon that were small
enough that the dots actually look like
they're on the line everybody's clear
about what I'm drawing so now of course
if you're a statistician you don't see
this you only see this and you have to
recover this guy and it's going to look
like this right you're gonna have an
estimated line which is the red one and
the blue line which is the the true one
the one that actually generated the data
and your question is well this line
corresponds to some parameters a hat and
B hats how could I make sure that those
two lines how far those two lines are
and one way to address this question is
to say how far is a from a hat and how
far is B from B hat okay another
question of course that you mask is how
do you find a hat and B hat and as you
can see it's basically the same thing
remember what was
so Abby was the covariance between x and
y divided by the variance of X right
which I can rewrite as the expectation
of XY minus expectation of x times
expectation of Y divided by expectation
of x squared minus expectation of X the
whole thing's okay if you look at the
expression for B hat I basically
replaced all the expectations by bars
right so I said well this guy I'm going
to estimate by an average so that's the
so X Y bar is 1 over n sum from eiko 1
to N of X I times y I X bar of course is
just the one that we're used to and same
for y bar x squared bar the one that's
here is the average of the squares and X
bar square is the square of the average
okay so you just basically replace this
guy by x-bar this guy by Y bar this guy
by X square bar and this guy by X bar in
the square okay so that's basically one
way to do it every where you see an
expectation you replace it by an average
that's the usual a statistical hammer
you can actually be slightly more subtle
about this and as an exercise I invite
you to just to make sure that you know
how to do this competition it's gonna be
exactly the same kind of competitions
that we've done but as an exercise you
can check that if you actually look at
say well what I wanted to minimize here
I had an expectation right and I said
let's minimize this thing
well let's replace this by an average
first and now minimize okay so if I do
this to that I'm gonna actually get the
same result the minimum of the average
is basically this when I replace the
average by the sorry when I replace the
expectation by the average and then
minimize that's the same thing as first
minimizing and then replacing
expectation by averages in this case
again this is a much more general
principle because if you don't have a
closed form for the minimum like for
some say likelihood problems well you
might not actually have a possibility to
just look at what the formula looks like
see where the expectations show up and
then just plug in the averages instead
so you might this is the one you want to
keep in mind and again as an exercise
okay so here and then you do expectation
replaced by averages and then that's the
same answer in I I encourage you to
solve the exercise
okay everybody is clear that this is
actually the same expression for a hat
and we had that we had before where we
that we had for a nd when we replaced
the expectations by averages here by the
way I minimize the sum rather than the
average it's clear to everyone that this
is the same thing right yeah so we did
switch the derivative and the
expectation before you came
all right so indeed the picture was the
one that we said so visually this is
what we're doing we're looking among all
the lines for each line we compute this
distance right so if I give you another
line there would be another set of
arrows you look at their lengths you
square it and then you sum it all and
you find the line that has the minimum
sum of squared length of the arrows all
right and those are the errors that
we're looking at but again you could
actually think of other distances and
you would actually get different you
could actually get different solutions
right so there's something called
mean absolute deviation which rather
than minimizing this thing is actually
minimizing the sum from I equal 1 to N
of the absolute value of y minus a plus
BXI and that will that's not something
for which you're gonna have a closed
form as you can imagine you might have
something that sort of implicit but you
can actually still solve it numerically
and this is something that people also
like to use but way way less than the
least squares one
what did I just what the sum of the
absolute values of Y I minus a plus BX I
so it's the same except that I don't
have the square okay
so arguably you know predicting price a
demand based on price is a fairly naive
problem typically what we have is a
bunch of data that we've collected and
we're hoping that together they can help
us do a better prediction all right so
maybe I don't have only the price but
maybe I have a bunch of other social
indicators maybe I know the competitor
competition the price of the competition
maybe I know a bunch of other things
that are actually relevant and so I'm
trying to find a way to combine a bunch
of points a bunch of measures let's say
for example there's a nice example that
I like which is people who are trying to
measure something related to your body
mass index butts so basically the volume
of your the density of your body and the
way you can do this is by just you know
really weighing someone and also putting
them in some you know cubic meter of
water and see how much overflows and
then you have both the volume and the
and and the mass of this person and you
can you know start computing density but
as you can imagine you know I would not
personally like to go to a gym where the
first thing they ask me is to just go in
some bucket of water and so people try
to find ways to measure this based on
other indicators that are much easier to
measure for example I don't know the
length of my forearm and the
circumference of my head and maybe from
maybe my my belly would probably be more
appropriate here and so you know they
just try to find something that actually
makes sense and so there's actually a
nice example where you can show that if
you measure I think one of the most
significant was with the circumference
of your wrist this is actually a very
good indicator of your your body density
and it turns out that
if you stuff all the bunch of things
together you might actually get a very
good formula that I explained things
alright so what we're gonna do is rather
than saying we have only one X to
explain why's let's say we have 20 X's
that we're trying to combine to explain
why and again just like assuming
something of the form Y is a plus B
times X was the simplest thing we could
do here we're just going to assume that
we have Y is a plus B 1 X 1 plus B 2 X 2
plus B 3 X 3 and we can write it in a
vector form by writing that Y I is X I
transpose B which is now a vector plus
epsilon I okay and here on the board I'm
gonna have a right hard time doing
boldface
but all these things are vectors right
except for Y which is a number right Y
is a number it's always the value of my
y-axis okay so even if my x-axis lives
on this is X 1 and this is X 2 y is
really just a real valued function and
so I'm gonna get a bunch of points x1 y1
and I'm gonna see how much they respond
right so for example is the my body
density is y and then all the X's are a
bunch of other things agreed with that
so this is an equation that holds on the
real line but this guy here is in our p
and this guy is in our p it's actually
common to talk to called b beta when
it's a vector and that's the usual
that's the usual linear regression
notation Y is X beta plus epsilon so X's
are called explanatory variables Y is
called explained variable or dependent
variable or response variable it has a
bunch of names you can use whatever you
think feel more comfortable with they
shoot it should actually be explicit
right so that's all you care about now
what we typically do is that rather so
you notice you that there's actually no
intercept if I actually fold that back
down to one dimension there's actually a
is equal to zero right if I go back to P
is equal to one
that would imply that why I is well say
beta times X plus epsilon and I and
that's not good I want to have an
intercept and the way I do this rather
than writing a plus this and you know
just have like a an overload of notation
what I'm actually doing is that a
fullback I fold my intercept back into
my X and so if I measure twenty
variables I'm going to create a twenty
first variable which is always equal to
one
okay so you should need to think of X as
being one and then x1 X P and now I'm
sorry X P minus one I guess okay and now
this is an R P okay so the way I'm
always gonna assume that the first one
is one I can always do that if I have a
table of data if my data is given to me
in an Excel spreadsheet and here I have
the density that I measured on my data
and then maybe here I have the height
and here I have the wrists circumference
and I have all these things all I have
to do is to create another column here
once I just put one one one one one one
okay that's all I have to do to create
this guy well great and now my X is
gonna be just one of those rows okay so
that's this is X I this entire row and
this entry here is why I okay so now for
my noise coefficients I'm still going to
assume as for the same thing except that
here the covariance is not between X
between one random variable and and
another random variable is between a
random vector and a random variable okay
how do I measure the covariance between
a vector and a random variable
yeah so basically Wow okay yeah so yeah
baby in the you know covariant vector is
equal to zero is the same thing as its
norm equal to zero but yeah this is
basically a part of entry wise for each
coordinate of X I want that the
covariance between epsilon and this very
this coordinate of X is equal to zero so
I'm just asking this for all coordinates
again in most instances we're gonna
think that epsilon is independent of X
and that's something we can understand
without thinking about coordinates all
right so yeah I'm sorry can you repeat
their question here
yeah beta is the parameter we're looking
for right just like it was a and the
pair a B has become the whole vector
beta now so there's no well you can you
think of an intercept of a function that
takes I mean there is there is one
actually that's the one for which betas
all the betas that don't correspond to
the vector of all ones so the intercept
is really the weight that I put on this
guy that's the beta that's gonna come to
this guy but we don't really talk about
any set in two dimensions if sorry if X
lives in two dimensions the way you want
to think about this is uh you take a
sheet of paper like that alright so I
have now I have points that live in
three dimensions all right so let's say
one direction here is x1 this direction
is X 2 and this direction is y okay and
so what's gonna happen is that I'm gonna
have like my points that live in this
3-dimensional space and what I'm trying
to do when I'm trying to do a linear
model for those guys when I assume a
linear model what I assume is that
there's a plane in those three
dimensions so think of this guy as being
going everywhere and there's a plane a
lot close to which all my points should
be alright that's what's happening in
two dimension if you see higher
dimensions than congratulations to you
but I can't all right so but you know
you can definitely formalize that fairly
easily mathematically and just talk
about vectors
all right so now here if I talk about
the Li squared error estimator or just
the least squares estimator of beta it's
simply the same thing as before just
like we said so remember you should
think of B as being as beta as being
both the pair a B generalized okay so we
said oh we wanted to minimize the
expectation of Y minus a plus B x
squared right now that's in for P is
equal to one now for P less than or
equal to two we're just gonna write it
as Y minus X transpose beta squared okay
so I'm just trying to minimize this
quantity of course I don't have access
to this so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna replace my expectation by an
average so here I'm using the notation T
because beta is the true one and I don't
want to - just so here I have a variable
T that's just moving around and so now
I'm gonna take the square of this thing
and when I minimize this over all T in
our T the argument the minimum is
attained at beta hat which is my
estimator okay
so if I want to actually compute yeah
you mean the previous life so again I'm
just defining an estimator just like I
would tell you just take the estimator
that has coordinates for everywhere yeah
so
yes and so the answer is yes I'm I was
just trying to think if this was
captured so it is not captured in this
guy because this is just telling me that
the expectation of epsilon I minus
expectation of Sun is equal to zero okay
yeah so yes I need to have that epsilon
I has mean 0 let's assume that X
expectation of epsilon is 0 for this
power
okay and we also need we're gonna need
something about some sort of question
about the variants being not equal to
zero right but this is gonna come up
later
so let's think for one second about
doing the same approach as we did before
take the partial derivative with respect
to the first coordinate of T with
respect to the second coordinate of T
with respect to the third coordinate of
T etc so that's what we did before we
had two equations and we reconciled them
because it was fairly easy to solve
right but in general what's gonna happen
is we're gonna have a system of
equations we're gonna have a system of P
equations one for each of the
coordinates of T and we're going to have
P unknowns each coordinate of T and so
we're gonna have the system to solve
actually turns out is going to be a
linear system but it's not gonna be
something that we're gonna be able to
solve coordinated by quadrant it's gonna
be annoying to solve you know you can
guess that what's gonna happen right we
hear it involved the covariance between
X and epsilon right that's what it
involved to understand sorry the
coordinate the correlation between x and
y to understand how this the solution of
this problem was in this case there's
going to be not only the correlation so
the covariance between X 1 and Y X 2
eggs and Y X 3 etc all the way to X P
and Y there's also going to be all the
cross covariances between XJ and XK and
so this is going to be a nightmare to
solve like in this system and what we do
is that we go on to using a matrix
notation so that when we take
derivatives we take derivative we talk
about gradients and then we can invert
matrices and solve linear systems in a
somewhat formal manner by just saying
that if I want to solve the system a x
equals B rather than actually solving
this for each coordinate of X
individually I just say that X is equal
to a inverse times all right so that's
really what Y we're going to the the
equation 1 because we have a formalism
to write that X is the solution of this
system I'm not telling you that this is
going to be easy to solve numerically
but at least I can write it ok
and so here's how it goes I have a bunch
of
vectors I have so what are my vectors
right so I have x1 oh by the way I
didn't actually mention that when I put
the lowercase when I put the subscript
I'm talking about the observation and
when I put the superscript I'm talking
about the coordinates right so I have X
1 which is equal to 1 X 1 1 X 1 P X 2
which is 1 X 2 1 X 2 P all the way to X
n which is 1 X + 1 X and P all right so
those are my n observed
X's and then I have another Y 1 y 2 y n
that comes paired with those guys ok so
the first thing is that I'm gonna stack
those guys into some vector that I'm
gonna call Y so maybe I should put an
arrow for the purpose of the blackboard
and it's just Y 1 2 y n ok so this is a
vector in RN now if I want to stack
those guys together
I can either create a long vector of
size n times P but the problem is that I
lose the role of whose a coordinate and
whose whose a at observation and so it's
actually nicer for me to just put those
guys next to each other and create one
new variable and so the way I'm gonna do
this is rather than actually stacking
those guys like that I'm gonna take
their transpose and stack them as rows
of a matrix ok so I'm gonna create a
matrix which here is denoted typically
by I'm gonna write X double bar and here
I'm gonna actually just so since I'm
taking those guys like this the first
column is gonna be only once and then
I'm gonna have well X 1 1 X 1 P and here
I'm going to have x + 1 X and P okay so
here the number of rows is n and the
number of columns is P one row per
observation one column for Gordon a
and again I make your life miserable
because this really should be P minus
one because I already use the first one
for this guy I'm sorry about that it's a
bit painful so usually we don't even
write what's in there so we don't have
to think about it those are just vectors
of size P okay so now that I create this
thing I can actually just basically
stack up all my models so why I equals x
I transpose beta plus epsilon I for all
I 1 to N this transforms it - this is
equivalent to saying that the vector Y
is equal to the matrix x times beta plus
a matrix plus a vector epsilon where
epsilon is just epsilon 1 - epsilon n
right so I have just this system which I
write as a matrix which really just
consistent stacking up all these
equations next to each other alright so
now that I have this model this is the
usual discourse model and here when I
want to write my least squares criterion
in terms of matrices write my lease
price criterion remember was sum from I
equal 1 to n of y I minus X I transpose
beta squared well here it's really just
the sum of the square of the
coefficients of the mate of the vector Y
minus X beta so this is actually equal
to the norm squared of Y minus X beta
squared that's just the square norm is
that by definition the sum of the square
of the coordinates and so now I can
actually talk about minimizing the norm
squared and here it's gonna be easier
for me to take derivatives alright so
we'll do that next time